how does the passive investing and kind
of that discipline plan mess with active
strategies and kind of this world of the
individual investor who thinks they can
pick stocks probably not going to be
very good at it
but there are professionals who are
pretty good at kind of active management
etc how do you you know kind of balance
those two things as you think about just
portfolio management general okay so the
base case what I like to call asset
allocation for dummies is it doesn't
really matter what you do going back to
what I said earlier
but this starting point for almost
everyone if you don't have a waypoint or
a compass is what I call the global
market portfolio that means if you went
out and bought the entire world of
public assets and the things that are
missing in public world is private homes
and farmland and some private real
estate but but if you to buy every
public asset in the world what does it
look like you end up with a portfolio
that's roughly half stocks and half
bonds and of that it's roughly half US
and half foreign and that's a great
portfolio as a starting point but most
people want to kind of skew that
depending on you know what their their
own interests and and start to tilt away
from their ninety percent of what I
talked about in our research you know
our white papers our books is the like
final 10%
you know we wrote a few remember back
again probably too young but back
decades past they had this old food
pyramid where the government recommended
what people should eat the most of and
then sparingly all the way to the top
and it's funny to look back on because
the the base for everyone used to just
be carbs it was like bread cereal pasta
Pino pizzas like totally inverted today
on what people think would be good good
advice and then the same thing probably
applies to your investing but but in
general you do the big muscle movements
first and are the things at the top
worth doing I think so
I have a lot of departures from the
standard advice but this goes back to a
John Bogle quote where he says I said
indexing work for him for example are
there approaches that are better sure
but there's infinite worse and so
finding one that works for you
important it's easy to stay to set your
risk tolerance to say look I'm fine
losing 50% and we talked about a lot of
people used to ask me hey Matt this get
rich portfolio how do you get how do you
hit 20 percent returns how do you 30%
returns and I said here's some ways but
frankly most you probably can't handle
it because on paper you say you can
handle down 50 down 80 and then when it
hits the fan you probably can't and we
did a tweet and this is kind of
happening in real time and said usually
don't see bad behavior until people see
minus 20 and then it gets exponentially
worse every 10 down from there so that's
the base case what I call the global
market portfolio and if anyone did that
it's fine by the way
there's a 2,000 year-old portfolio
called the Talmud portfolio where it
says let every man invest a third of his
wealth in land a third in business and a
third keep in reserve so I call that
real assets stocks bonds that beats the
vast majority of institutions over time
we've done some articles called why
CalPERS should be managed by a robot why
Harvard should be managed by a robot how
to clone Ray Dalia's all whether
Bridgewater all of these are pretty hard
this 2,000 year old portfolio does a
pretty good job of replicating what all
these do with thousands of people tons
of fees tons of effort headache you just
buy his portfolio done okay so that's
the base case now let's say you want to
start tinkering with that and by the way
my personal portfolio largely mirrors
the Talmud portfolio which is I do it a
little bit differently because my
background my family and my dad side
came from a farming background in Kansas
and Nebraska
my old man grew up on a farm straight up
no running water or all that stuff so
farming is sort of in my blood so a
third is in farm land a third is in
private businesses because I know that
I'm friggin horrible about behaviorally
selling things so over 150 private
companies and then then there's the
public assets okay I think there's some
important tilts that make a lot of sense
and the two big found a
the pillars to which to build from in my
mind are nothing new it's nothing that
we've invented but that goes back 100
years so one over 100 years goes back
hundreds of years but famously a hundred
years in the u.s. one being value so Ben
Graham you know one of the famous most
famous people talk about that and then
on the other side is what I would call
trend falling and momentum which Charles
Dow you know creator of the Wall Street
Journal but also talked a lot about
trend following early twentieth century
we talking on valuation first it's
actually pretty easy to come up with an
estimate of how stock market's going to
do the next ten years this isn't my
equation it's actually John bogles
equation you know one of the greatest
contributors of the well-being and
success of investors all over the world
particularly in the u.s. over the last
50 years he wrote a paper in the 90s and
I call it bogus formula obviously he
would never say to use it for timing or
forecasting but he would say just to set
expectations and it's super simple in as
three variables you want to know the
stock returns the next decade it's
starting dividend yield then it's
dividend growth and then it's change in
valuation and that's it now the dividend
growth you can kind of explode into
inflation and real dividend growth or
you could also call it earnings growth
but same thing so historically and I'm
gonna round here going back to 1900 the
dividend yield of almost around 5% gone
are those days although they may be soon
coming back depending on what the
markets happening today dividend growth
also almost 5% and change evaluations
should be washed over ending nineteen
twenty nineteen there was a slight edge
to that in the US as the US stock market
got more expensive over over the past
hundred twenty years and so you can plug
in parts of that equation and find out
where we are so at the end of last year
dividend yield let's round up and call
it 2% let's say you got the same
dividend growth as historical and the
nerds out there who are listening by the
way the dividend growth is actually a
little bit higher than historical
because of the way buybacks have sort of
changed that equation but it's a wash
mostly because the inflation is low
the big varial comes with a change in
valuation and so we ended 2019 at a
long-term price earnings ratio of around
32 I think and historical average is
around 18 now if you have low inflation
you could say it's around maybe 21 so
it's high again it's not crazy like the
late 90s were 45 but but it's high and
so you can plug that in the equation and
say look John Bobo said this before he
passed by the way said investors should
expect
I think low single-digit returns the US
stock market for the next decade now he
his point wasn't sell everything and be
done with it but rather just lowered
expectations take your medicine and
maybe save more or just have real estate
and Vanguard publishes very similar
returns the problem of course comes that
most investors expect 10% always every
survey natixis just did one where they
surveyed investors all around the world
in the last year they expected 11.7 real
so you got to add on inflation and I
think the survey is probably not fair
because most investors have a hard time
distinguishing between nominal real but
really that means like 14 percent but
even at eleven point seven is crazy
because markets have never returned that
in history ever so the problem you see
is this massive dislocation between
valuations so that was the bad news but
you put that in the US and you say look
every kuan shop on the planet a QR
research billions cheemo yada yada would
say low single digit returns expectation
some would say even negative so a pretty
bad opportunity set now the good news is
the rest of the world is cheaper so
we'll use end of last year and then we
can update it foreign stocks were
trading around average valuations for
low inflation so let's call it 21
emerging market John around 15 and the
cheapest bucket cheapest quartile is
down around 12 and historically tilting
towards value has been a great way to
add let's call it one to four percent
returns over market cap weighting the
problem is obviously it comes in chunks
you know it doesn't happen every year
and as we've seen this year it certainly
can get worse and the beautiful thing
about valuation is it's hard right the
stuff that's cheap so end of year I mean
we're talking Russia Brazil
all Greece Italy Singapore I mean Norway
just nasty who's who the worst countries
of geopolitical of economic news you
know the prices because they've already
declined sixteen eighty percent and on
the right side the good stuff that's
hitting new highs everything's rosy at
least it was a few months ago right the
u.s. lowest unemployment on record had
the first decade in history with no
recession the first year in history
calendar year when stock market went up
every year in 2017 on and on right
everything looks great but one of the
biggest things about using valuation is
it's not just about buying the cheap
where there's massive career risk nobody
wants to own those names because if you
do and they go down on your clients say
what are you talking about we own Russia
and Brazil and Greece in Italy you're
fired
if they do great they're pounding back
what you're supposed to do everyone
wants to own the expensive stuff but
using valuation is every bit as much
about avoiding the expensive as it is
investing in the cheap and going back to
our examples of avoiding the u.s. when
it was the largest market cap country in
1999 avoiding Japan would hit a Pho
hundred and has had negative returns the
next 30 years and that's not some
backwater economy right Japan is the
still with top-three economy in the
world so doing those two things is hard
that's why you make it systematic you
put the rules in place you have it so
that you tilt towards Bali I mean look
this is Warren Buffett 101 it's not that
hard